in the old days air traffic control was
didn't really exist as such an airplane
want to fly from one place to another
would just take off and would try to
work out how to get to ever it was going
over time it was realized that we needed
some form of air-traffic control in
order to more or less to avoid airplanes
from banging into one another but also
to provide them with a service so that
they actually would know what the
conditions were on route and so on and
so forth so
during the fifties and sixties what
evolved was the idea of an air traffic
control center where once the airplane
was away from the environment of the
airfield we now had a control center
which would then manage the aircraft
through what's called the Airways system
and the Airways is up a high level it's
once you've got away from the airport
then you're into the airway system the
next problem was how do we actually make
all that work now in the old days you'd
literally have had a controller sitting
in front of the radar and assistants
running around with flights trips taking
them from one controller to the other
and that clearly wasn't going to work in
the longer term essentially a flight
strip when a commercial flight flies it
files what's called a flight plan and
the flight plan says what the the flight
intends to do where it's going from
where it's going to what its routing is
what type of aircraft it is and so on
and so forth quite a lot of information
and essentially that ends up by becoming
a flight strip which follows that flight
around by the mid to late 60s we were
started to try to introduce computers
into this effectively to coordinate the
movements of traffic and particularly to
ensure the controller had the
information that he required but also
that they hand over between controllers
as the flights progressed was done in a
structured kind of fashion when we get
down to 1970 we actually have a control
room that's at West Drayton and what
that was doing was providing control for
everything in the airway system from the
south coast right the way up to the
Scottish border there's an equivalent
one at Prestwick which does Scotland and
then basically pushes the aircraft out
across the Atlantic each one of these
hoods here is effectively a radar sector
an area of airspace which is controlled
by that controller so what you've got
here is a couple of controllers the
director who is overall in charge of
that sector and effectively what's
happening is as the flight progresses it
moves from sector to sector until
eventually it disappears outside of the
British air control controlled airspace
one of the early attempts was to put in
a computer called the myriad this is in
around the rate late sixties into about
nineteen seventies it takes a long time
to develop this sort of software and by
the time the software had actually been
developed so it reasonably was in a
reasonable working condition
air traffic it increased to such an
extent that the myriad was no longer
capable of doing the job in fact it
wasn't capable of even
during the civil job it was originally
designed to do civil and military it was
designed for fault tolerance
environments so it was a xxx system
three computer systems effective they're
all all three computer systems were
doing the same job and what would happen
is then an arbitrator would decide who
got the right answer
hopefully all three got the same answer
but if they didn't then it would decide
which was the most likely answer
basically two out of three was the
arrangement we were continually chasing
up against the limitations of what the
computer systems could do the next
attempt was really when it's all started
working which was in 1972 or there
abouts the Board of Trade as it was then
decided that it was going to go out and
procure the fifty-third I think it was
air traffic control system from the
United States because they already had
this sector eyes control system using
big IBM mainframe computers the IBM 360
is the underlying machine behind this
ten million pounds of that equipment in
1972 ish there abouts for the first time
we now had enough processing power more
or less to be able to do the job
completely what's being pictured here is
some of the initial testing that's being
done before the system went operational
we were testing all the various
different conditions and making sure
that if we did not nasty things to a bit
over here a bit over they didn't fall
over that's actually me running with one
of the tests sometime in 1974 it would
be I'd come back from the United States
where I went on the training course at
the end of 73 by 1974 I was in there
when I speak younger and thinner in
those days it was an extraordinary thing
I own I was twenty barely 22 when ironed
out the states and I was basically a
happy technician he was like all my
Christmases to come at once as a as a
youngster who was interested in
technology to have a 10 million pound
computer at my disposal was just just
extraordinary
we were actually encouraged to
particularly when we were on the
training course we were encouraged to
write software so I decided to one of
the things that I decide that try and do
was to write a game where the computer
played Monopoly and you can see here the
high speed printers these printers would
run at 600 lines per minute I wrote this
whole thing in assembler the computer
would make a move and it would then
print the Monopoly board so this thing
was throwing up pages like mad and as
the game progressed so the computer had
to do more and more
and so Ethan got slower and slower so it
wasn't quite throwing the pages the same
to the speed
everything was paper-based this was
before the days of VD use we didn't have
VD use and things like that this is the
existent control here the system control
there is effectively the center of
gravity of this entire system but we
then have is three compute elements
which are IBM 360 65 s which in they pay
you were quite powerful computers they
had behind them now get this three and a
half mega words of memory core memory
three and a half mega words yeah they're
32-bit words so what would that be
around about 14 megabytes or something
of that order of RAM and we ran the
whole of the National air traffic
service on that without any problem in
fact we could run it on about three of
them we had seven storage elements and
we could run with three we prefer to
have four so each one was half a mega
word and then behind those three
input/output controllers which would I
be m3 60 50s now the IRC II didn't put
output control elements was responsible
for talking to all the various different
pieces of equipment they were attached
to this so we had flight strip printers
radar systems all sorts of things all
feeding information in or receiving
information out from the 9020 and they
were managed by the IEEE input/output
patrol elements which you can't see
there just behind there the system
actually worked for quite a long time in
fact it was in service as this system
itself right the way through till 1990
when it was replaced by 43 81 computers
or to a third of the size and something
like ten times more powerful but
essentially running exactly the same
software in emulation mode in 360
emulation mode so this was still at West
ratin and really that was mostly done
because this was quite old equipment
even when it was first put in and so it
was becoming too expensive to maintain
the skills and knowledge necessary to
maintain it we were effectively becoming
difficult to find now so that was the
reason that was done and that kept
things going right the way through
really until the early 2000s when it
became apparent that really what was
happening now was the computing was
moving away from the large mainframe
environment a much more distributed
architecture by now we have networking
we have the ability to have mini and
micro computers which is where they
where we
want them rather than having in them in
a major computer suite
so really the west drayton environment
wasn't designed for that it was designed
with the idea of having central
processing bays and lots lots and lots
of cables running underneath ducts under
the floor too to where they were going
to be used in addition the RAF who
actually owned the west drayton site
they kind of wanted it back so there's
lots of reasons why eventually in the
early 2000s we started looking at the
idea of moving to a new control center
this is Swannack and effectively that
completely replaced the West rate and
setup interestingly however some of the
code which was written way up here back
in the 1970s is actually still in use to
this day down here a friend of mine who
worked together with me on a lot of this
software going back to the early
seventies he said hey you know I was I
was kicking around in some code the
other day just looking at D says and I
came across your initials against the
line of code he says I thought about you
so the thing is if this software still
works it ain't broke
so why fix it that the problem of air
traffic control is continually evolving
but the core functions are exactly the
same it takes a long time to get it all
debugged so we might as well keep with
the code that we've already got however
over time eventually that code will be
replaced but it's it's a slower process
this was a major exercise getting this
to work in the in the sentences so
they're really sort of sweating the
assets and taking advantage of the fact
is extremely reliable code we'd like to
thank audible for supporting
computerphile and if you go to
audible.com slash computer file there's
a chance to sign up for a 30-day free
trial and download a free audio book the
book I'd like to recommend is Ernest
Cline's ready player one I enjoyed it so
much I went often downloaded these other
book Armada as well but ready player one
is well worth checking out if you love
the idea of a seamless VR system
dystopian future lots of 80s pop culture
references I know a lot of people have
been recommending ready player one it's
currently being made into a film so
check it out and thanks once again to
audible for supporting the computer file
channel the other two canisters are
actually butane cylinders which were
discarded and they act kind of like a
Gasca pastor they're called accumulators
and they store gas close to where it
comes out so that it can come out
quickly